>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND A
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
AT SOME POINT, IT WAS HARD TO
IMAGINE NOW, THE CURRENT
REVOLUTION WILL END.
THEY CAN BE SUSTAINED AND YOU
WILL WAKE UP ONE MORNING IN A
COUNTRY WHERE WE DON'T HAVE TO
LIE ABOUT EVERYTHING ALL THE
TIME WHERE MASS IS ALLOWED,
WHERE WE CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THE
PROFOUND AND INHERENT
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN MEN AND
WOMEN WITHOUT BEING FIRED FOR
IT.
THAT DAY IS COMING.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT WILL BE
LEFT FOR SOCIETY?
WE CAN'T KNOW THE ANSWER IN
DETAIL BUT HERE'S WHAT WE ARE
HOPING FOR, THAT REASON REMAINS.
LOGIC, THE ABILITY TO THINK
CLEARLY AND RATIONALLY, THE ONE
THING WE CAN'T LOSE, GOING TO
NEED IT TO REBUILD.
THAT'S WHY OF ALL THE MORAL
ATROCITIES BEING COMMITTED AT
THE MOMENT IN THE NAME OF EQUITY
AND INCLUSION, IT'S THE
RELENTLESS ATTACKS ON SCIENCE I
SHOULD COMMAND OUR SPECIAL
ATTENTION.
SO FOR THE NEXT HOUR, WE WILL
CONSIDER THOSE ATTACKS IN SOME
DETAIL AND START WITH AMERICA'S
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT PANDEMIC.
WHEN THE CORONAVIRUS FIRST
ARRIVED IN OUR COUNTRY LAST
WINTER, MOST AMERICANS
UNCRITICALLY ACCEPTED WHAT THE
AUTHORITIES SAID ABOUT IT.
IF YOU IMAGINED OUR LEADERS
WOULD LEVERAGE A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY FOR THEIR OWN
POLITICAL GAIN, THAT SEEMED LIKE
THE ONE LINE THAT EVEN
POLITICIANS WOULDN'T CROSS AND
YET ALMOST IMMEDIATELY, THEY
CROSSED IT.
AROUND THE COUNTRY, DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS USED QUARANTINE
RESTRICTIONS TO REWARD THEIR
ALLIES AND TO PUNISH THEIR
OPPONENTS.
ABORTION MILL STAYED OPEN BUT
THE POLICE KEPT CHURCHES CLOSED.
YOU COULD BUY WEED, BUT COULDN'T
GET YOUR KNEE REPLACED.
DEMONSTRATIONS AGAINST LOCKDOWNS
WERE BANNED, RIOTS AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP WERE ENCOURAGED.
WATCH THE GOVERNOR OF MICHIGAN
SHAMELESSLY EXPLAIN THE
DIFFERENCE.
>> IT IS PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
BE SAFE TO CONGREGATE IN MASSES
FOR QUITE A WHILE AND IT'S
HEARTBREAKING.
WE KNOW THAT MICHIGAN IS NOT
ALONE IN THIS MOMENT.
THIS IS WHAT'S HAPPENING ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THESE BIG
GATHERINGS JUST CAN'T SAFELY
HAPPEN RIGHT NOW.
THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD IS
ONCE AGAIN SHONE A LIGHT ON A
SYSTEMATIC CYCLE OF INJUSTICE IN
OUR COUNTRY.
TO THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY WHO
HAVE TAKEN TO THE STREETS AND
PROTESTED PEACEFULLY, PROTESTING
HISTORIC INEQUITIES, THOSE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE FACING, I
HEAR YOU, I SEE YOU.
I RESPECT YOU, AND I SUPPORT
YOUR EFFORTS TO ENACT REAL,
STRUCTURAL CHANGE IN AMERICA.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE NO
LONGER ALLOWED TO EXERCISE YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF ASSEMBLY
UNLESS IT IS TO PUBLICLY SUPPORT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND IT WASN'T JUST THE GOVERNOR
OF MICHIGAN, GAVIN NEWSOM TO THE
SAME THING IN CALIFORNIA, PHIL
MURPHY DID IN NEW JERSEY.
IT WAS PARTISAN POLITICS POSING
AS SCIENCE AND THIS WAS THE MOST
AMAZING PART.
IT WAS ENDORSED BY ACTUAL
SCIENTISTS AND THAT'S THE PART
THAT SHOULD WORRY YOU.
HE TOLD US THAT STRUCTURAL
RACISM WAS A BIGGER HEALTH
THREAT IN THE CORONAVIRUS SO GO
AHEAD AND LOOT MACY'S, AN
IMPORTANT PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
FOR THOSE WHO STILL BELIEVE THAT
AMERICAN SCIENCE WAS ON THE
LEVEL, THIS WAS A SHOCKING
MOMENT, WHEN DID THEY BECOME
CORRUPT RELIGIOUS ZEALOTS, WHEN
DID SCIENTISTS BECOME
AYATOLLAHS?
IT HAPPENED YEARS AGO, THE REST
OF US JUST FOR NOTICING.
AND FEBRUARY 2019, PIECE WAS
PUBLISHED IN THE JOURNAL OF
NEUROLOGY WHICH IS ONE OF THE
PREEMINENT PEER-REVIEWED
PUBLICATIONS AND ALL OF
MEDICINE.
IT WAS CALLED LUCKY ON THE ROOT
DR. DESCRIBED EXPERIENCE WHEN A
MAN IN THE DEEP SOUTH CALLED
REGGIE WAS SUFFERING FROM A
SEVERE NEUROMUSCULAR DISORDER
WHICH HAD LEFT HIM BLIND.
MODERN SCIENCE MIGHT HAVE HELPED
REGGIE, BUT HE DIDN'T WANT TO
HELP.
REGGIE BELIEVED HE WAS BLIND
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN CURSED BY A
VOODOO SPELL AND THEN HE REFUSED
TREATMENT AND LEFT THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE FOR GOOD.
THE DOCTOR WHO WROTE THIS PIECE
WAS A MAN CALLED WILLIAM
CAMPBELL, BELIEVED IN WESTERN
SCIENCE, HE DID NOT BELIEVE THAT
VOODOO WAS THE CAUSE OF
BLINDNESS AND THE PIECE HE WROTE
WAS DESIGNED TO HELP OTHER
PHYSICIANS COMMUNICATE WITH
PATIENTS SO THEY COULD RECEIVE
EFFECTIVE MEDICAL TREATMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY, AMERICAN MEDICAL
JOURNALS ARE NO LONGER ALLOWED
TO CRITICIZE WITCHCRAFT.
IT'S RACIST.
SO THE EDITOR OF NEUROLOGY BEGAN
A PURGE OF HIS OWN PUBLICATION,
HE FIRED THE HUMANITIES EDITOR
AND SUSPENDED THE ENTIRE SECTION
AND THEN TO FURTHER RATON,
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
THEN ROBERT GROSSES IF THIS
WASN'T ENOUGH ROAD OF GROVELING
APOLOGY LETTER FOR THE PEACE
CALLING HIS ARTICLE RACIST AND
ACKNOWLEDGING THEY HAD CAUSED
ENGLISH.
NOWHERE IN THAT LETTER DID HE
EXPLAIN ANY OF THIS.
WHY EXACTLY IS IT RACIST TO
PREFER WESTERN MEDICINE TO
WITCHCRAFT?
ISN'T THAT THE WHOLE POINT OF
OUR SYSTEM?
HE NEVER EXPLAINED, JUST
DECLARED IT RACIST AND MOVED ON
SO THAT THE OFFICIAL POLICY OF
THE TOP NEUROLOGY JOURNAL THAT
WITCHCRAFT IS THE SAME AS
WESTERN MEDICINE AND HOW DARE
YOU SAY OTHERWISE.
WHERE DOES THIS LEAVE YOU?
IF YOU ARE NERVOUS ABOUT BRAIN
SURGERY BEFORE, THIS IS NOT
COMFORTING NEWS, HOW LONG BEFORE
THEY SACRIFICE A CHICKEN IN THE
OPERATING ROOM?
THAT'S A SERIOUS QUESTION.
WE CAN NO LONGER SAY SCIENCE IS
BETTER THAN VOODOO, THAT'S
RACIST.
SOMETHING SIMILAR HAS HAPPENED
IN THE WORLD OF ECONOMIC
RESEARCH, ONE OF THE TOP
BUSINESS JOURNALS IN THE WORLD,
DELETED A PAPER FROM THE
INTERNET WITHOUT ANY
EXPLANATION.
THE KEY THING TO KNOW IS ALL THE
NUMBERS IN THAT PAPER WERE
ACCURATE AND THEY WERE RIGHT.
NO ONE CLAIMED OTHERWISE.
THE PIECE WENT THROUGH PEER
REVIEW AND WAS PUBLISHED.
IT WAS PUBLISHED BECAUSE IT WAS
CALLED THIS WEIRD "EXAMINING
INVESTOR REACTIONS TO
APPOINTMENTS OF BLACK TOP
MANAGEMENT EXECUTIVES AND
CEOs."
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THOSE
REACTIONS WERE, MIGHT BE
INTERESTING TO KNOW BUT YOU
CAN'T KNOW BECAUSE THE ORIGINAL
VERSION HAS DISAPPEARED.
IT IS GONE, NOW IN A REMOTE CAVE
WHERE WE HIDE UNCOMFORTABLE
FACTS AND BEEN REPLACED BY A
HEAVILY REVISED VERSION SO IT'S
THE TRUTH?
WE CAN'T KNOW.
THIS IS THE FURNISHING OF
CORRUPTION BUT IT HAS SPREAD
THROUGH SCIENCE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE JOBS POSTINGS
THAT NATURE MAGAZINE, ONE OF THE
FOREMOST SCIENCE PUBLICATIONS ON
THE PLANET.
WHEN NATURE IS LOOKING FOR NOW
HAS NOTHING WHATSOEVER TO DO,
IT'S ANTISCIENCE, HERE'S A
RECENT JOB POSTING ON TWITTER,
"AS PART OF OUR COMMITMENT TO
FOSTER DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION,
WE ARE LOOKING FOR A BLACK
CANDIDATE WITH A PASSION FOR
SCIENCE COMMUNICATION BASED IN
THE U.K. FOR A FULL TIME PAID
INTERNSHIP."
SO THE THING THAT JUMPS OUT IS
THAT NO WHITES OR ASIANS OR
HISPANICS ARE ALLOWED.
IS THAT LEGAL?
OF COURSE IT'S NOT LEGAL BUT
THAT'S NOT REALLY THE POINT.
THE BIGGER PROBLEM HIM AND IT IS
BIGGER THAN CIVIL RIGHTS LAW IS
THAT THE PEOPLE WE TRUST TO MAKE
THE MOST IMPORTANT DECISIONS IN
OUR SOCIETY, ESSENTIAL
DECISIONS, WHAT KIND OF MEDICAL
RESEARCH TO REFINE, WHO GETS
TREATMENT AND WHO DOESN'T, WHO
LIVES AND WHO DIES, THE PEOPLE
WHO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS ARE NO
LONGER RATIONAL.
THEY HAVE LOST THE ABILITY TO
THINK EMPIRICALLY.
EQUITY IS NOW THE